This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1939, an astonishing new machine debuted at the World's Fair in New York City. It was called the Voter, short for voice, operating demonstrator. It looked sort of like a futuristic church organ. That's our own Delaney Hall. An operator, known as a voterette, would sit at a curved wooden console. Behind her, there was a huge wall with an art deco image of a man's face with these spirals of curly hair. His mouth was a giant speaker.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1939年，一台令人惊叹的新机器在纽约世界博览会上首次亮相。它被称为“Voder”，是“语音操作演示器”（Voice Operating Demonstrator）的缩写。它看起来有点像未来派的教堂管风琴。那是我们的德莱尼·霍尔。一位被称为“Voderette”的操作员会坐在一个弯曲的木制控制台前。在她身后，有一面巨大的墙，上面画着一张装饰艺术风格的人脸，有着螺旋状的卷发。他的嘴是一个巨大的扬声器。
The voterette would place her hands on two keyboards in front of her, each with five or six wide keys. She'd use her feet to work two pedals down below, but instead of musical notes, the machine produced a voice. This is from a demo recording of the voter produced in 1939 around the same time as the world's fair. Each of the keys on the keyboard controlled a particular frequency band. One foot pedal controlled pitch and the other foot pedal controlled whether the sound would be muffled or crisp.
操作员会将双手放在面前的两个键盘上，每个键盘有五到六个宽大的琴键。她会用脚操作下方的两个踏板，但机器发出的不是音符，而是人声。这段录音来自1939年世界博览会期间制作的Voder演示录音。键盘上的每个琴键都控制着特定的频段。一个脚踏板控制音高，另一个脚踏板控制声音是低沉还是清脆。
Operating this machine required incredible precision and skill. Voterats would train for up to a year to make the voter actually talk like a person. Or sing like a person. What about you sing a song for us? Will you? No, actually. Well, how about all-lengths? Oh, I'm so gay.
操作这台机器需要极高的精度和技巧。操作员最多需要训练一年，才能让Voder真正像人一样说话。或者像人一样唱歌。“你给我们唱首歌怎么样？好吗？”“不，其实不行。”“好吧，那全长音呢？”“哦，我太快乐了。”
She's so gay. Her feet are all angry. And remember, this is all happening totally live. The voterette is not triggering pre-recorded words. Instead, the keys and petals of the voter imitate the effects of the human vocal tract, producing the most basic building blocks of speech. The voterette is playing them in an intricate sequence, and she's actually synthesizing speech, real-time.
“她太快乐了。她的脚很生气。”请记住，这一切都是完全现场直播的。操作员并不是在触发预先录制好的单词。相反，Voder的琴键和踏板模仿了人类声道的效果，产生了语音最基本的组成部分。操作员以复杂的顺序演奏它们，实际上是在实时合成语音。
The crowds at the world's fair went crazy for this talking machine. It created a sensation. This is John Paul. He's an engineer, inventor, and historian. It was the first time there had ever been working speech synthesis. Anywhere. People had no conception that you could even do it. Here's voter's imitation of a cow. The voter was invented by an engineer named Homer Dudley.
世界博览会上的观众对这台会说话的机器感到疯狂。它引起了轰动。这是约翰·保罗。他是一位工程师、发明家和历史学家。“这是有史以来第一次出现有效的语音合成。在任何地方。人们根本无法想象竟然能做到这一点。”这是Voder模仿牛的声音。Voder是由一位名叫霍默·达德利的工程师发明的。
And Homer Dudley's area of expertise was speech science. Dudley worked at Bell Labs, a research facility that belonged to AT&T. And during the 1920s and 30s, Bell Labs was doing all kinds of research into the human voice. How to synthesize it electronically, how to compress it so it could be sent across enormous distances quickly and cheaply, how to encode and disguise it. In all this research helped AT&T's basic goal, which was to improve the phone system in the United States.
霍默·达德利的专业领域是语音科学。达德利在AT&T旗下的研究机构贝尔实验室工作。在20世纪20年代和30年代，贝尔实验室正在对人声进行各种研究。如何以电子方式合成它，如何压缩它以便能快速且廉价地进行远距离传输，如何对其进行编码和伪装。所有这些研究都有助于AT&T的基本目标，即改善美国的电话系统。
The voter was a novelty offshoot, related to this research into speech, but it was closely connected to a number of Dudley's inventions at Bell Labs that still shape our world today. A lot of that basic research turned out to be things which have impacted our modern technology and world enormously. Stuff that became critical to the development of digital media, for example. And on top of all of that, Dudley's inventions helped us win a war. The Sambas 7, 1941, a date which will live in infamy. The United States will be in trouble. Just a couple years after the voters' debut at the World's Fair, Japan launched an early
Voder是这项语音研究的一个新奇分支，但它与达德利在贝尔实验室的许多发明密切相关，这些发明至今仍在塑造我们的世界。许多基础研究最终对我们的现代技术和世界产生了巨大影响。例如，成为数字媒体发展关键的东西。最重要的是，达德利的发明帮助我们赢得了战争。1941年12月7日，一个将永远蒙受耻辱的日子。美国将陷入困境。在Voder在世界博览会首次亮相仅几年后，日本发动了早晨
morning attack on Pearl Harbor in Hawaii. It came as a profound shock to the U.S. And the next day, President Franklin Delano Roosevelt announced the country would be entering World War II. With confidence in our armed forces, with the unbounding determination of our people, we will gain the inevitable triumph, so help us God." World War II would be the most widespread war in history. The US would be fighting in Europe and the Pacific and parts of North Africa all at the
对夏威夷珍珠港的袭击。这对美国来说是一个巨大的冲击。第二天，富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福总统宣布美国将参加第二次世界大战。“凭借对我们武装部队的信心，凭借我们人民无限的决心，我们将获得不可避免的胜利，愿上帝保佑我们。”第二次世界大战将是历史上最广泛的战争。美国将在欧洲、太平洋和北非的部分地区同时作战。
same time. And it was a huge challenge to coordinate troops across that much territory. It was obvious the only communication possible would be by radio. And that radio was, of course, insecure. The enemy is listening. In other words, there wasn't really anything besides radio that could stretch across the distances involved. But radio is easily intercepted. And so. The problem of encryption and secret messages of military importance became more and more serious. At the very start of the war, the US military still relied on an old-school piece of technology
在如此广阔的领土上协调军队是一个巨大的挑战。显而易见，唯一可能的通信方式是无线电。当然，无线电是不安全的。敌人正在监听。换句话说，除了无线电，真的没有什么东西能跨越这些距离。但无线电很容易被拦截。因此，军事重要性的加密和秘密信息问题变得越来越严重。在战争初期，美国军方仍然依赖一种老式的技术
for its sensitive conversations. It was called the A3 Scramble. It worked by scrambling voice frequencies, swapping high frequencies for low and low frequencies for high, garbling the sound. Here's an example of what it might have sounded like. But it was easy to decode these scrambled conversations. The A3 is being compromised and it was not a secure system. That's Dave Tomkins, who's researched the history of various speech synthesizers and their connections to music.
来进行敏感对话。它被称为A3扰频器。它的工作原理是扰乱语音频率，将高频与低频互换，将声音变得模糊。这是一个它听起来可能的样子。但这些扰乱的对话很容易被解码。“A3正在被破解，它不是一个安全的系统。”这是戴夫·汤普金斯，他研究过各种语音合成器的历史及其与音乐的联系。
German intelligence was essentially descrambling some of these conversations between FDR and Churchill in real time. And the US military knew the German codebreakers were listening in. So the US government gave Bell Labs the mission of creating an unbreakable speech and crypto. And Bell Labs went to our old friend Homer Dudley, the guy who invented the talking machine of the world's fair. They said, Dudley, we need you to figure this out. Really fast. They were under tremendous
德国情报部门基本上是在实时解密罗斯福和丘吉尔之间的一些对话。美国军方知道德国的密码破译员正在监听。因此，美国政府交给贝尔实验室一项任务：创建一种不可破解的语音加密系统。贝尔实验室找到了我们的老朋友霍默·达德利，那个发明了世界博览会会说话机器的人。他们说：“达德利，我们需要你弄清楚这一点。非常快。”他们承受着巨大的
wartime pressure to produce this thing quickly. I think the whole design took about a year. Thankfully, Dudley had already been working on technology related to this problem for years. It all went back to the voter and to another related invention of Dudley's called the Vocoder. Music nerds might know that term Vocoder because the great grandfather of the machine you hear in all kinds of pop music today. Vocoder was short for voice encoder, and the machine could break down a human voice, separate it into its basic components, and then compress and transmit those components
战时压力，要求迅速生产出这个东西。我想整个设计大约花了一年时间。值得庆幸的是，达德利多年来一直致力于与这个问题相关的技术。这一切都回到了Voder和达德利的另一项相关发明，即声码器（Vocoder）。音乐迷可能知道“声码器”这个词，因为它是你在当今各种流行音乐中听到的那种机器的鼻祖。声码器是“语音编码器”（voice encoder）的缩写，这台机器可以将人声分解，将其分离成基本组成部分，然后压缩并传输这些组成部分
via shortwave channel. It could transmit the minimal amount of signals required to reconstruct that message at the other end. This process was important, revolutionary actually, because it allowed the human voice to be digitized and compressed and sent across big distances. But the vocoder didn't fully disguise the voice. The transmission could still technically be pulled out of the air and decoded.
通过短波频道。它能传输在另一端重建该信息所需的最少信号量。这个过程很重要，实际上是革命性的，因为它允许人声被数字化、压缩并跨越长距离发送。但声码器并没有完全伪装声音。从技术上讲，传输信号仍然可以从空中截获并解码。
So Dudley and his team had to add a layer of unbreakable encryption. And that's how the vocoder became just one small part of a much larger and more intricate apparatus. A secure communications system that would allow allied military leaders in strategic locations around the world to talk in total secrecy. It was called Project X, aka the Green Hornet, aka Sig Sally. Which was short for nothing really. It was meant to be confusing. Each Sig Sally machine was enormous, weighing more than 50 tons.
因此，达德利和他的团队必须增加一层不可破解的加密。这就是声码器如何成为一个更大、更复杂装置的一小部分。一个安全的通信系统，将允许盟军军事领导人在世界各地的战略地点进行完全保密的交谈。它被称为“X计划”，又名“绿大黄蜂”（Green Hornet），又名“Sig Sally”。这名字其实没什么缩写含义，就是为了让人困惑。每台Sig Sally机器都非常巨大，重达50多吨。
It was a pretty complicated behemoth of a device. It wasn't even a device. It was a room in itself. It occupied about 2,000 square feet and was made up of 40 racks of equipment. It needed air conditioning because a lot of the electronics was so delicately balanced that if it got too hot or too cold it would not work properly. In fact the device was full of so many finely calibrated tubes and gadgets that the military created a whole division of engineers whose sole job was to maintain the machines. The 805th Signal Service Company.
这是一个相当复杂的庞然大物。它甚至不仅仅是一个设备。它本身就是一个房间。它占地约2000平方英尺，由40个设备架组成。它需要空调，因为许多电子元件的平衡非常微妙，如果太热或太冷，它们就无法正常工作。事实上，该设备充满了许多精密校准的电子管和小装置，以至于军方专门成立了一个工程师部门，其唯一的工作就是维护这些机器。第805信号服务连。
We're pretty much in charge of the installation and operation of the system. That's Don Mel, before he enlisted, he was an amateur radio operator from Omaha, and he was one of the engineers assigned to work on SIG Sally. He reported for duty in Washington, DC and spent his first two weeks in an intensive class. Where we learned all the technical details and the operations
“我们基本上负责系统的安装和操作。”那是唐·梅尔，在入伍之前，他是来自奥马哈的业余无线电操作员，他是被指派负责Sig Sally的工程师之一。他在华盛顿特区报到，并在强化班度过了最初的两周。“我们在那里学习了所有的技术细节和操作。”
and that was pretty much on the job training. The first SIG Sally terminal was installed in the basement of the Pentagon and it was connected to several conference rooms upstairs. Alligantly furnished, there was wine colored, thick, thick carpeting on the floor. They were beautiful rooms. This is Lieutenant Colonel Dorothy El Madsen. But my nickname is Meg, M-E-G. I was in charge of the Global Encrypted Conference Center. The conference center is where DC-based military leaders would
“那基本上就是岗前培训。”第一台Sig Sally终端安装在五角大楼的地下室，并连接到楼上的几个会议室。装饰华丽，地板上铺着酒红色的厚地毯。那是美丽的房间。这是多萝西·埃尔·马德森中校。“但我的绰号是梅格（Meg）。我负责全球加密会议中心。”会议中心是华盛顿特区的军事领导人
meet to speak over the Sixth Sallie system. So while Don Mel was down in the basement, running the machine, Meg was upstairs, coordinating conference calls with the military brass. She hosted everyone from President Harry Truman to General George Marshall. She sat in on their meetings and transcribed the conversations they had. Any of the men who had the responsibility for the conduct of the war and had to make their phone calls came to my conference center to do Communications is the most important thing and you have to do it with safety and security that you know nobody else is tuned in on it. The SIG Sally Terminal in the Pentagon was connected to a network of close to a dozen other SIGSALY terminals around the world. These were located in the most strategically important places where politicians and military leaders would need to be talking with each other on a regular basis.
开会通过Sig Sally系统进行交谈的地方。所以当唐·梅尔在地下室运行机器时，梅格在楼上协调与军方高层的电话会议。她接待了从哈里·杜鲁门总统到乔治·马歇尔将军的所有人。她旁听了他们的会议并记录了他们的谈话。“任何有责任指挥战争并必须打电话的人都会来到我的会议中心进行交谈。通信是最重要的事情，你必须在安全和保密的情况下进行，确保没有其他人监听。”五角大楼的Sig Sally终端连接到了全球近十几个其他Sig Sally终端的网络。这些终端位于政治家和军事领导人需要定期交谈的最具战略意义的地方。
El Jazeer and London and Paris eventually and Hawaii and Guam and Australia. There was even a SIGSALY terminal based on a roving ship in the Pacific. And one in beautiful, strategically important, Oakland, California. This network allowed leaders in Washington, DC to talk securely with any location that had a terminal. All they needed was a shortwave radio connection, and one other key component. A pair of vinyl phonograph records of totally random noise. This is where the encryption part comes in, because for every conference that happened over Sixth Valley, both the sending and
阿尔及尔、伦敦、巴黎，最终还有夏威夷、关岛和澳大利亚。甚至还有一台基于太平洋巡逻舰上的Sig Sally终端。还有一个在美丽且具有战略意义的加利福尼亚州奥克兰。这个网络允许华盛顿特区的领导人与任何拥有终端的地点进行安全交谈。他们只需要一个短波无线电连接，以及另一个关键组件：一对完全随机噪声的黑胶唱片。这就是加密部分发挥作用的地方，因为对于通过Sig Sally进行的每一次会议，发送和
receiving terminals had to have identical records, which played the sound of noise. The noise would combine with the voice components as they were transmitted via shortwave radio, making it impossible for eavesdroppers to decrypt. On the receiving end, the random noise would be extracted in the voice restored. In cryptography, these records are what's known as a one-time key. So here's how they worked. Random noise would be generated, and then pressed on a gold master. Normally a phonograph record you would reproduce thousands of them from a gold master. Normally a phonograph record, you would reproduce
接收终端都必须拥有完全相同的唱片，播放噪声的声音。噪声会在通过短波无线电传输时与语音成分结合，使窃听者无法解密。在接收端，随机噪声会被提取出来，语音会被还原。在密码学中，这些唱片被称为“一次性密钥”。这就是它们的工作原理。随机噪声会被生成，然后压制在金母盘上。通常，黑胶唱片你会从一个金母盘复制出数千张。在这种情况下，他们只制作了正好两张唱片。
thousands of them from a single master. In this case, they made exactly two records. The identical and now totally unique records would be assigned a matching code name. And these code names were awesome. Like red strawberry, or wild dog, or circus clown. So let's say President Harry Truman in Washington, D.C. wants to talk with Prime Minister Winston Churchill in London.
这些相同且现在完全独特的唱片会被分配一个匹配的代号。这些代号非常棒。比如“红草莓”、“野狗”或“马戏团小丑”。假设华盛顿特区的哈里·杜鲁门总统想与伦敦的温斯顿·丘吉尔首相交谈。
Truman keeps one of the two records in Washington, D.C. The second one would be sent to the station at the other side of the ocean. And then placed on this special precision turntable. That was a part of the Six-Sally Terminal. At the scheduled time for the conference, Six-Sally Engineers in DC and London would tune in to WWV. which is the International Time Control Station, so that we could synchronize our control clocks exactly. Then they get their identical records spinning on their respective turn tables
杜鲁门在华盛顿特区保留两张唱片中的一张。第二张会被送到大洋彼岸的站点。然后放在这个特殊的精密转盘上。那是Sig Sally终端的一部分。在预定的会议时间，华盛顿特区和伦敦的Sig Sally工程师会调到WWV，即国际时间控制站，以便我们能精确同步我们的控制时钟。然后他们让各自转盘上相同的唱片旋转
at exactly the same moment. Once the records were synced, Truman would speak into a handset in Meg's conference room at the Pentagon. This is the President, Mr. Prime Minister. This is a reenactment of Truman and Churchill greeting each other into a handset in Meg's conference room at the Pentagon. This is a reenactment of Truman and Churchill greeting each other when they talked to be a SIG Sally to discuss a German surrender proposal in 1945. The signal would go down into the basement where Don was running the SIG Sally terminal.
在同一时刻。一旦唱片同步，杜鲁门就会对着五角大楼梅格会议室里的听筒说话。“总统先生，首相先生。”这是杜鲁门和丘吉尔在1945年讨论德国投降提议时，通过Sig Sally交谈时的重演。信号会传到唐运行Sig Sally终端的地下室。
The terminal would digitize Truman's voice, mix it with random noise from the record, and then transmit that signal across the ocean via shortwave radio. On the other end, the Sixth Valley terminal in London would reverse the process. It would remove the noise, reconstruct the voice, and feed it through Churchill's handset. After so much processing and such a long distance, the voice didn't sound very good. Like gibberish orated from the bottom of a barrel. But it was intelligible. You had to kind of train your ear a bit.
终端会将杜鲁门的语音数字化，将其与唱片中的随机噪声混合，然后通过短波无线电将该信号跨洋传输。在另一端，伦敦的Sig Sally终端会反向执行该过程。它会去除噪声，重建语音，并通过丘吉尔的听筒传出。经过如此多的处理和如此长的距离，声音听起来不太好。就像从桶底发出的胡言乱语。但它是可以理解的。你必须稍微训练一下你的耳朵。
Anyway, then Churchill would reply, How glad I am to hear your voice. And the whole process would be reversed. Oh, but I am to hear your voice. In this way, Truman and Churchill could have a completely secure real-time conversation, planning, plotting, and strategizing about the war. When the conversation ended, the two records, which, remember, contained the top secret random noise key, would be destroyed.
无论如何，然后丘吉尔会回答：“听到你的声音我有多高兴。”整个过程会反过来。“哦，听到你的声音我也很高兴。”通过这种方式，杜鲁门和丘吉尔可以进行完全安全的实时对话，计划、策划和制定战争战略。当谈话结束时，那两张包含绝密随机噪声密钥的唱片会被销毁。
That's because if anyone was recording this communication as it traveled over the ocean, the random noise record would be the key to decrypting it. It would allow them to subtract the noise in the same way the Six Sally engineers did at each end of the transmission. So the records were the most classified and sensitive component of Six Sally. By the end of World War II, there had been a total of about 3,000 top secret strategic conferences. In other words, at least 6,000 vinyl records that were pressed, delivered, used, and then destroyed at the end of the call.
这是因为如果有人在通信跨越海洋时对其进行录音，随机噪声唱片将是解密它的关键。它将允许他们以Sig Sally工程师在传输两端所做的方式减去噪声。因此，唱片是Sig Sally中最机密和最敏感的组件。到第二次世界大战结束时，总共进行了约3000次绝密战略会议。换句话说，至少有6000张黑胶唱片被压制、交付、使用，然后在通话结束时被销毁。
Compared to today, it was a bit of a rudimentary type of technology, but for that time, we're in a vast nobody even thought of voice communications in terms of being digitized. And because of SIGSALA, the US was able to communicate with the Allies in real time and by voice. So if people were listening in to that signal, if Germans were listening in, what would they hear? Nothing but random noise, just total white noise. Wow. I mean, it might have been so unintelligible that they didn't even realize they were listening
与今天相比，这是一种相当原始的技术，但在那个时候，我们处于一个广阔的领域，甚至没有人想到语音通信可以数字化。由于Sig Sally，美国能够与盟军进行实时语音通信。所以如果有人在监听那个信号，如果德国人在监听，他们会听到什么？除了随机噪声，什么都没有，完全是白噪声。“哇。我的意思是，它可能太难以理解了，以至于他们甚至没有意识到他们正在监听
to anything at all. They never knew of the existence of the system, and they never had any inkling that it was an encrypted speech. In fact, that's why Sig Sally was nicknamed the Green Hornet, after the popular 1940s radio show. The Green Hornet. Because an intercepted Sig Sally transmission sounded like nothing more than a hornet's buzz. SIG Sally was involved in pretty much every major military operation after 1942. It was even critical in the planning of the Manhattan Project and the dropping of the atomic bombs over Japan. Don Mel was the engineer decrypting and listening in on those six Sally conversations, even though
任何东西。”他们从未知道该系统的存在，也从未怀疑过它是加密语音。事实上，这就是Sig Sally被昵称为“绿大黄蜂”的原因，源自20世纪40年代流行的广播节目《绿大黄蜂》。因为被拦截的Sig Sally传输听起来不过是黄蜂的嗡嗡声。Sig Sally参与了1942年后的几乎所有重大军事行动。它甚至在曼哈顿计划的规划和向日本投掷原子弹的过程中也至关重要。唐·梅尔是负责解密和监听那些Sig Sally对话的工程师，尽管
he didn't know at the time the meaning of the code words they were using. And obviously the she's coming over and the title is Manhattan Project. Well, I of course didn't know what the Manhattan Project was. Don didn't reflect much on the grave implications of those meetings he overheard. He was an engineer, doing his best to keep the equipment running. You didn't pay that much attention to everything that was said to your Mark in concern with the transmission. But he knows it would have been hard for the allies to win the war without Sig Sally.
当时他并不知道他们使用的代号的含义。“显然，她要过来了，标题是曼哈顿计划。好吧，我当然不知道曼哈顿计划是什么。”唐并没有过多思考他无意中听到的那些会议的严重影响。他是一名工程师，尽其所能保持设备运行。“你并没有太注意所有关于传输的谈话。”但他知道，如果没有Sig Sally，盟军很难赢得战争。
It's hard to say what we would do if we didn't have it. Even if that victory sometimes came at a brutal price. At the end of the war, the SIG Sally terminals were dumped in the ocean. Almost every encryption device was intentionally destroyed when the war was over for security purposes to the extent of destroying the plans. But not before the military developed successors that were smaller and simpler and easier to set up. These new devices still worked on the same principles of encryption as SIG Sally, and they were used for secure communications during the Cold War, the Korean War, and to negotiate the Cuban Missile Crisis.
“很难说如果我们没有它会怎样。”即使这种胜利有时付出了残酷的代价。战争结束时，Sig Sally终端被扔进了大海。几乎所有的加密设备在战争结束后都被故意销毁，出于安全目的，甚至销毁了设计图。但在那之前，军方开发了更小、更简单、更容易设置的后续产品。这些新设备仍然按照与Sig Sally相同的加密原理工作，并被用于冷战、朝鲜战争期间的安全通信，以及谈判古巴导弹危机。
A lot of the information related to SIG Sally wasn't declassified until the mid-1970s, when AT&T sued the US military under the Freedom of Information Act. Once it was public, technology that originated with SIGSALI went on to entirely new realms. The vocoder, for instance, went on to have a whole new life in music. In the 1970s, electronic musicians like Kraftwerk
许多与Sig Sally相关的信息直到20世纪70年代中期才解密，当时AT&T根据《信息自由法》起诉了美国军方。一旦公开，源自Sig Sally的技术就进入了全新的领域。例如，声码器在音乐中获得了全新的生命。20世纪70年代，像Kraftwerk这样的电子音乐家
began using a smaller version of the machine to create weird robotic vocal effects. We have a rock. From Germany, the vocoder spread to the Bronx in Brooklyn, where hip hop and electro-funk group started playing around with it. Now you hear it all over the place. But the vocoder's reach actually goes way beyond the robot voice.
开始使用该机器的较小版本来创造怪异的机器人人声效果。“我们有摇滚。”从德国开始，声码器传播到了布朗克斯和布鲁克林，嘻哈和电子放克乐队开始尝试使用它。现在你到处都能听到它。但声码器的影响实际上远远超出了机器人声音。
You're also using vocoder every time you use your mobile phone. But of course in a much much reduced size. The giant clunky machine of the past now occupies the space of a tiny chip, which compresses speech and allows hundreds of conversations to pass through a single cell phone tower. And a lot of the technology used to transmit media on the internet can be traced back to Dudley too. That includes MP3 music, that includes video compression. So give thanks to Homer Dudley every time you watch something on the internet. All those millions of viral videos would take up too much space if they couldn't be compressed. Jolly bit me.
你每次使用手机时也在使用声码器。当然，尺寸要小得多。过去笨重的巨大机器现在占据了一个微小芯片的空间，它压缩语音并允许数百次对话通过单个手机信号塔。许多用于在互联网上传输媒体的技术也可以追溯到达德利。这包括MP3音乐，这包括视频压缩。所以每次你在互联网上观看东西时，都要感谢霍默·达德利。如果不能压缩，所有那些数以百万计的病毒式视频将占用太多空间。“乔利咬我。”
Oh my God, it's full of undouble rainbow all the way across the sky. Everything in our modern digital world of media can be traced back to Dudley's vocoder and to Sig Sali. In the end, the vocoder kind of came full circle. It started its public life as a silly novelty gag, making animal noises for crowds at the 1939 World's Fair. And here's a pig. Then, like Don Mal and Meg Matzen, the vocoder enlisted. It did its service. It held the allies when the biggest war the world had ever known.
“天哪，它充满了双彩虹，横跨整个天空。”我们现代数字媒体世界中的一切都可以追溯到达德利的声码器和Sig Sally。最终，声码器兜了一圈又回到了原点。它作为一种愚蠢的新奇把戏开始了它的公共生活，在1939年世界博览会上为人群制造动物声音。这是猪的声音。然后，像唐·梅尔和梅格·马岑一样，声码器应征入伍。它履行了职责。它在世界历史上最大的战争中帮助了盟军。
And now, it's back to civilian life. Making silly noises once again. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Delaney Hall, with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Avery Trollfum and Kurt Col Stead, Sharif Yusef, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Dave Tompkins' author of How to Rec a Nice Beach, the Vocoder from World War II to Hip Hop. His book inspired this episode and gets into the history of how the Vocoder
现在，它又回到了平民生活。再次制造愚蠢的声音。《99%隐形》本周由德莱尼·霍尔制作，凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特罗尔芬和库尔特·科尔斯特德、谢里夫·优素福以及我罗曼·马尔斯参与。本周特别感谢《如何录制好海滩：从二战到嘻哈的声码器》一书的作者戴夫·汤普金斯。他的书启发了这一集，并深入探讨了声码器如何
jumped from the military into popular music. Thanks also to Ben and he vet Sennak of Nucleus, David Conn, author of the Codebreakers and Stephen Jackson. And finally thanks to Pat Masidio Miller, who played the voice of President Harry Truman, Winston Churchill was played by our new staffer, Man of a Thousand Voices, to refuse F. We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxan, the East Bay's premiere architecture and interior firm firm in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and, like the show on Facebook, follow us all on Twitter and Instagram,
从军事领域跳跃到流行音乐的历史。还要感谢Nucleus的本和伊维特·塞纳克、密码破译者作者大卫·卡恩和斯蒂芬·杰克逊。最后感谢帕特·马西迪奥·米勒，他扮演了哈里·杜鲁门总统的声音，温斯顿·丘吉尔由我们的新员工、千声之人特鲁夫·F扮演。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Arxan（东湾首屈一指的建筑和室内设计公司）办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞我们的节目，在Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，
but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to become good friends with our website. It's 99pi.org What's the matter? That sounds great, T-Pan. Let's get a little less vocoder on. You want less vocoder? Yeah, far away too much like a robot. Okay, I'll ask. Hey, vocoder, T-Pain wants a little less effect on this.
但探索塑造我们世界设计的《99%隐形》活动的最好方式是与我们的网站成为好朋友。网址是99pi.org。“怎么了？”“听起来不错，T-Pain。声码器效果少一点。”“你想要少一点声码器？”“是的，太像机器人了。”“好的，我问问。嘿，声码器，T-Pain想要这个效果少一点。”
I think it sounds great. Radio tapia. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“我觉得听起来很棒。”来自PRX的Radio Tapia。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。